Hi everyone we are looking at break-even analysis not broke even analysis is like John Travolta is trying to tell us but we are looking at break-even analysis we're trying to understand what that means the context of the firm and briefly to say it means this is going to be the price or quantity that matches your total revenue and your total cost so that let's you know where that point is that you do want to stay in business or you do not want to stay in business.
Graphically speaking.
It looks something like this.Now, we're going to keep this simple by having a total revenue curve that is upward sloping it doesn't look like the one that comes from chapter 6.
Ah, but it does look like this in the sense that price is some whatever price happens to be $10 for example and we can sell as many units at $10 as we won't and that causes our total revenue to always be increasing. We also have our total cost.
The total cost here are also going to be linear just to keep it simple it doesn't look like the turtle cost that come out of the closet chapter instead it's just going to be this nice little your car that we can deal with that we know are fixed costs are always going to be fixed horizontal it doesn't change that is we're going to have those cost regardless.
So when we look at the break-even quantity we can clearly see where that happens to beat it is where our total revenue curve and our total cost curve intersect one another so that point right there.
Any area above anyone see above that breaking quantity right here.
Is going to generate profit.
Any break-even quantity here is going to generate a lost so what we are looking for is trying to understand where is my total revenue equal to my total cost because that is going to help us figure out the break-even quality is going to help us figure out the break-even priced and it's going to help us figure out a whole lot of things about your problem with the company simply because we know where we want to start.
So let's look at the Breakeven formula now we've already mentioned that total revenue equals total cost right that is where we find the break-even quantity that let's rearrange the equation to look like this 0 equals total revenue minus total cost all we did was pull total cost over to the other side and now we have a formula that can help us figure out what it wants to eat and the price of going to be to break even now let's figure out just a little bit more we know that total revenue is simply our price times our quantity and we also know our total cost come from fixed cost plus any marginal cost of production so are fixed costs.
And in the marginal cost of making a unit times the amount of units that we make so let's rewrite the equation to be zero equals P times Q -.
FC was MC X cute so all we've done is simply take the total revenue minus total cost and expanded the equation to help us better understand what we're looking at now we have some like terms that we can group together Universe we have a Q right here and you have a few right there so let's group The Light rooms together and that is going to give us 20 equals.
Price minus marginal cost.
Tom's our output Quan pork used minus the fixed cost now what we need to do is isolate that Q by itself.